Google cloud next 2017 hosted a litany
of tork detailing the future of cloud if
you didn't get a chance to catch the
session developing for speed
minimizing app latency at scale then
stay tuned because here is the recap
[Music]
you're a good developer so you already
know the importance of having a fast app
lower latency correlates to an increase
in user engagement sales and user
satisfaction
now latency is the delay between a
request and its response and application
latency specifically is how this delay
manifests and affects the end user which
is important as little as a hundred
millisecond increase in page latency can
cause a round a 1% drop in revenue which
means that the ultimate goal is to
manage latency in a holistic manner to
maximize user satisfaction you know
you've done a good job when performance
plays no part in a user's experience
they simply don't notice it a good rule
of thumb is to focus your attention on
making your most common operations the
fastest and aligning behavior with user
expectations see users intuitively
expect some operations will take a bit
longer for example creating a new file
or saving one now even for operation and
when that's not the case or where the
delay is likely longer than they're
expecting you can manage those
expectations by telling users the
operation may take a while from a user
perspective to perceived latency is the
time spent interacting with the UI the
actual latency and the difference
between their expectations there are
some great ways to make your app feel
like it's loading faster without
actually decreasing if actual latency
provides instant feedback animate
straight transitions and cache your UI
components so that they appear
immediately showing UI even if it can't
be interacted with will decrease the
perceived latency if you want to improve
the actual latency the first step is
monitoring it Google Analytics lets you
specify user timings to investigate the
distribution of latency values for
different actions and the difference in
values across different demographics
including regional differences another
great tool is stack driver using tracing
you can view latency numbers in real
time plotted on a scatter graph and dig
deeper by selecting individual traces so
that
ever also produces reports including
sampling traces at different percentiles
for you to look at when you identify a
high latency function or request type
that CPU bound then profiling lets you
dig deeper once you've identified
potential latency issues it's time to
mitigate them one great approach is to
find out where your users are and put
your compute and storage resources near
them to help use the Google cloud CDN or
a content delivery network to take
advantage of Google's globally
distributed edge points of presence to
catch HTTP load balance content close to
your users above all else focus on use
of satisfaction with a holistic approach
that includes both front end and back
end if you're interested in more ideas
about how to use Google CDN and details
on performing and performance analysis
on your apps check out the full talk on
YouTube and if you want more recaps on
great next content make sure to check
out the rest of our playlist and don't
forget the Google cloud summit coming
soon to a city near you
[Music]
you